Diesels are highly popular in Ukraine.
This Volkswagen Passat has just arrived from
Germany - it meets Euro-5 emissions standards.
Some mechanics take a close look at it.
They know it'll need adapting to Ukranian
standards within a few months at the latest.
That's when they'll have to remove its catalytic
converter.
The catalytic converters and the particle
filters often cause problems.
They get clogged up very quickly and stop
working.
The diesel quality's too low here.
Without emissions control systems the diesels
pump unfiltered toxic gases and particles
straight into the air.
And because regular inspections for cars are
not legally required in Ukraine, exhaust systems
can be manipulated without fear of detection.
It's easy for experienced mechanics to remove
an exhaust emissions control unit - and replace
it with a section of plain pipe.
This component comes from a Renault diesel.
If a catalytic converter is clogged up, the
vehicle won't start.
We hook it up with the diagnostic computer.
The problem is very often a clogged up catalytic
converter.
Sometimes we cut the converter out, sometimes
we can repair it.
The Ukrainian city of Lutsk has a population
of 240 thousand.
The air is foul.
And 82 percent of the pollution comes from
cars and trucks.
There's an automarket here twice a month - trading
mostly diesels.
Private operators import the cars, mostly
from Germany.
Diesels meeting older emissions standards
which get registered in Poland or Lithuania
are treated as transit vehicles for up to
a year.
Only the later Euro-5 standard cars are actually
allowed to be imported.
Germany worries about the environment and
that's why the price of diesels is falling.
Germany understands its people and spends
a lot of money on environmental protection.
Throughout the city a number of stations are
constantly measuring air quality.
The results show that only two other Ukrainian
cities have filthier air than here.
And now Lutsk is filling up with sub-standard
German diesels.
The air will most certainly become dirtier,
because diesel's a fuel that is so bad for
the environment.
Diesels have become hard to sell in Germany,
and now they're flooding into eastern European
markets.
The Germans have simply outsourced their diesel
emissions problems.